[Music]
thanks for being here you are a very
busy fellow you've got a lot of movies
going on i'm here right yeah yeah
exactly you made that is the measuring
stick exactly anyone who can make it
here has got to be busy uh you just
isn't my right you just finished
shooting a movie where you play john f
kennedy i did yes uh which is easy yeah
i would say probably one of the hardest
people to play i think because uh such
an iconic look but also
the accent so specific and almost
different i would think impossible to do
yes uh virtually impossible you're from
boston i'm from boston very well i know
the accent but whenever i do it it's
really me doing mayor quimby from the
simpsons
yeah you know that's damn it that's what
i did yeah
oh my simpson yeah that uh
that is good i hear it it's good i can
get in there a little bit but if you're
really trying to portray him accurately
what was the technique that you use i
would go to sleep listening to the um
the podcasts of his speeches so i you
know it's uh so that was helpful what
are the what are the most difficult
words or the words that you have
i had a tough time with hemosphere
the word hemisphere and he would use
knives for a lot of saying hemisphere
you'd say hemosphere
it was a diphthong there i guess is what
that's called um i had to deliver some
of his speeches which was pretty cool um
so you know it's a daunting thing
stepping into those shoes obviously um
but it's it's not a movie about john f
kennedy so it's uh so i'm okay yeah
three or four days of work it was uh it
was it it's a it's a movie uh that
portrait it's uh called the butler it's
the butler it's the account of the
butler who served at the white house
over eight presidencies and all the
presidencies uh all the presidents are
sort of peripheral characters but it's
his account um through ike and uh robin
williams plays like big cass oprah
winfrey's in the movie robin williams
plays eisenhower plays eisenhower yeah
we all have lots of prosthetics on and
wigs obviously
you're kidding no robin williams plays
eisenhower yeah ooh
ooh he's just like you know he hasn't
said he hasn't said shaw's bot in 50
years and yet that's my go-to for robin
williams yes
oprah is in the movie she's a big star
big star i've heard of her yeah um a
wonderful wonderful woman she plays
jimmy carter
that's why i'm in the movie
experimental character yeah yeah that
sounds insane
uh it's crazy yes wonderful woman met
her when she was doing her camera test
came over gave me a hug oh that's nice
smelled wonderful she tell us what oprah
smells like she smelled like diamonds